often the way to find what you're good
at is by thinking about what you're not
good at so just like in the process of
your one word
some people find it easy to find their
one word their most important core value
by going positive thinking about all the
good things in their life and figuring
out what their
most important core value is some people
can't get down to it
only going positive they find it better
going opposite going negative
so think about the people who you can't
stand being around what values do they
have
what's just like toxic to you you can't
stand being around these kinds of people
i'm being in these kinds of situations
and by figuring out that that's your
anti-word you can figure out
your one word and so think about what
you hate doing
think about what other people may like
doing the people around you they enjoy
doing but for you it's like i can't
believe people like doing that
what would you absolutely hate spending
your time on
every single day and that gets you to a
list of weaknesses and the opposite will
be what you're really good